hello everyone
here is dr shooting from jan script
today i would like to introduce you a
novel high throughput test for detection
of sas cover 2
neutralizing antibody
so before the talk i want to give you a
brief look of how the
today's webinar will be first i will
give you some simple facts about sales
copy 2
and then i will introduce you about our
c-pass kit
afterwards of course i will explain to
you why
c-pass kit is important to use and why
you should choose it
in the end i will tell you explain to
you the importance
of neutralizing antibodies in the whole
combat
with covet 19 and of course i will end
with a short
summary for today's talk
so about south kova ii i think here
today there will be no one says
i don't know about this virus according
to who
uh until yesterday's data there are
currently 130 million
cases reported that is infected with
kobe 19 more than 2.8 million deaths
associated with coffee 19 were also
reported globally
unfortunately while we are talking this
number is still rising rapidly
so how does cytoskovit reach this level
of pandemic
first of all as we can see from the
scheme of the virus
on the left side suscover2 virus also
known as scorpio 19 it has a very simple
viral structure
it encodes s protein e protein
covers with envelope on the top of the
envelope has m protein
and also within the virus it has a viral
rna
and associated with m protein
so how the virus enters our host cells
it has to give the credit to the virus
as protein
also known as spike protein within the
spike protein there is a part called
receptor bending domain also known as
ability
this domain can interact with the whole
cell third surface receptor ac2
and with this interaction allows the
virus into the whole cells
and thus replicate in the host cells
if the interaction is blocked with a
neutralizing antibody
this virus cannot invade the cells
anymore
and here today so how do we detect the
cells copy2
as we already know there are different
ways to detect
the virus infection and at different
time frames
the most common way as we see is the pcr
test this allows you to determine the
viral load
in the infected patients with
besides the pcr test we also have the
so-called
serology test also known as antigen test
it can be either a quick test or it can
also be a elisa test
both tests allow you to detect post
infection of the antigen response within
the patient
so what is c pass what can cpas do
see past neutralizing neutralization
antibody detection kit also known as
as vnt detects the circulating
neutralizing antibodies
against the south copy ii that block the
interaction between the receptor binding
domain
as we know rbd domain of the s protein
with the ac2 receptor
so as we already know what's the
definition of c pass elisa kit
how does it really work the c-pass kit
is designed for detection
the neutralizing antibodies with the
patient
plasma or serum samples so once you have
your samples ready
you can just take 10 microliter of the
samples
and inoculate with the kid-provided
rbd domain reagent this reagent
this rbd domain is conjugated with a
reported protein hrp so as you can see
from the figure
the neutralizing antibodies when it
existing
in the samples it will block the rbd
domain
primer which interacts
where the uh green color indicates
non-neutralizing antibodies either
does not bend to the ability to abdi
domain at all
or it could also possibly bind to the
other parts
of the rbd domain
after the inoculation time we transfer
all the samples into our 96
well elisa plate those plates
are coated with the ac2 receptors on the
well bottom
we allow them to fully interact with
each other
at 37 degrees with this temperature you
will allow the
unblocked rbd domain to bind to the ac2
receptor steadily
and you can know afterwards we can wash
all the rbd domain away which was
blocked
or neutralized by the neutralizing
antibodies
and then we can read the plates with the
signal
of od as a readout
so you can see this mechanism of c-pass
kit
is quite easy so why should i choose
c-pass
what's so special about this kit
as you know before c-pass kit there are
other ways to determine the neutralizing
antibody
within the samples one of the most
conventional way
or traditional way is so-called virus
neutralization
essay it's this essay
needed the life virus attendance
and because of that reason it takes two
to three days to perform the essay
and also it needs s3 lab because we need
to
use the live coronavirus
additionally to perform this essay you
need
a highly trained expertise to do the
experiment and also to interpret
interpret the data
this essay could be quite expensive due
to the production of the virus
and performing of the lensi experiment
with the c-pass kit compared to this
traditional essay
it is much faster it just takes up to
two hours
for one performance and can be highly
automatable
also this work doesn't allow needed
a s3 lab because it can be performing
any laboratory settings as
it just needs incubator and the elisa
reader
it can be done of course in a high
school throughput way
as you know it's quite easily performed
and also this essay is much more
consistent
as you see it is only
with the elisa kit so
this is the most conventional way but
what is the gold standard of the
neutralizing
essay as we know the plaque reduction
neutralization test
and you see from our manual uh data
we compared our kit results with the
most
gold standard up pr nt50
and prnt90 both essays showed hundred
percent
agreement with the c-pass kit therefore
the specificity and sensitivity of of
our kid compared to this
plaque essay is perfect
so at this moment i guess you also have
the question
what's the difference of c-pass kit and
other serology tests that determine the
quantity of igg or igm
so as you can see here uh with our assay
we
involved the receptor coated on the
bottom of our plate
due to this reason that's also why we
called the
thyrogate virus neutralization test
we can really detecting the function on
neutralizing antibodies against the
cover too
and you have the readout with
the rbd domain bending to ac2 when the
neutralizing antibody works
there will be no signal at all
neurology tests that claim they could
interpret the neutralization
functions also they have typically the
rbd domain coated on the elisa plate
with that you can see from the skin
that maybe they are detecting the
neutralizing antibodies
but it could also give you false signal
when the antibodies
binds to the other parts of rbd domain
instead of
exactly the timer that interacts with a
receptor
in order to show this in a more
statistic way we also performed an
internal test as you see here the blue
bar shows
accumulation of s1 uh
protein as we use the antigen test
and the red line
indicating the neutralizing activity
using our c-pass kit
so they are not really correlated
additionally with traditional antigen
tests
nowadays they are mostly focused on igg
and igm however with this essay they
could
simply missing an importance of iga
and c-pass kid is detecting the total
and neutralizing antibodies against the
f-protein
of thus covalent ii it not distinguished
igg
igm or iga so we are also detecting
aga in our test studies already shown
that aga
dominates the early neutralizing
antibody response to south korean 2.
this figure uh showed you that post the
infection of kobe 19
within up to two weeks the iga
dominates in the antigen response
in this blue line
uh another figure from this same
research showed you that
the purified aga has a much higher
neutralizing ability compared to the igg
which
conventionally people like to detect
posted the infection of south korea too
importantly and interestingly
here today we have some feedback from
our current customers
told us that c-pass kit could also be
potentially used for detection of saliva
as we all know that igg is mainly
existing in the salipa samples so
a saliva test in c-pass could be an
alternative for the future to detect
determine the neutralizing
antibody level in the patients
so besides all that what else
that cpas can offer to you of course
as i mentioned before c c-pass is very
fast tool
and easy to handle tool to deter
detecting the neutralizing antibodies
additionally c-pass is also species
independent a characterization from the
animal model and
to human clinic studies can be performed
with c-pass kit
here today there are many studies
already used the c-pass kit
for animal samples including mouth
non-human primates rabbit bats dog cats
and pangolin and so on
and very important of the c-pass kit is
this is virus-specific and there is
percent no cross reaction with
especially influenza a and b as we all
know that
influenza has quite similar symptoms as
uh cov19 so to distinguish them with a
simple
antigen test is also important and
crucial
for the kit and c-pass can offer you
that
importantly our c-pass kid already
received many important uh
regulatory approve approvals for
instance we have
the hsa
mark from in singapore we received the
ceivd mark
in europe and we also have the
fda ua authorization
uh of note c passed here today is still
the only one
fda ua authorized commercial elisa kit
for detecting neutralizing antibodies
against the coke
to accept coffee too
besides the current kids we have
extended our potential of
c pass we launched recently
a new neutralizing antibody standard
that allows
the kid for quantitative essay so you
can have your result
in unit per meal instead of percentage
of
inhibition so the antibody standard
is already on process of obtaining the
fda ua as well and ce ivd mark
so let's come to the last topic why
is it important to detect the
neutralizing antibodies
as well compared to the other you know
detection
of antigen
some studies already shown that there is
a poor correlation between
antigen test and neutralization
and you see from this data offered by
this particular
study they use different kids to detect
detecting the samples for a igg test
and then they also use a conventional
neutralizing
essay and you see the correlation
between the neutralizing activity
and the igt test is really bad
that's the paper or the research group
concludes that the commercial
serological assets have poor
mpa for south korea to neutralization
making them imperfect for neutralization
test
additionally another independent
research group
showed that the positive binding elisa
may not mean
positive neutralization result as we
already showed you before but this
study showed that within 218
participants that have already positive
elisa result for
the binding igg binding essay
only under sixty percent of the of the
patients have positive for
neutralization essay
another importance of why we have to
study neutralizing antibody
is due to the individual uh
immune response this study that
published quite
quite recently give us a first hint of
how
and why we have to detect the
neutralizing antibodies post
infection and validation so the study is
performed in singapore
and they have accumulated 517 samples
and this cohort study lasted up to nine
months long
so they are detecting the neutralizing
antibody response posted the natural
infection
and you can see here we can easily
distinguish the
response within five groups the first
group
is so-called negative groups they have
almost
no neutralizing risk antibody response
post the infection for the whole
nine months time the second group which
the
research group called them the rapid
warning
they seem to have a high enhancement of
the
neutralizing antibody immediately when
they explode
exposed to the virus infection however
this neutralizing antibody response
seems not lasting
within the virus infection and rapidly
dropped
to almost negative up to
two months or up to two to three months
the third group the green group is
so-called slow warning
so these start with very high immune
response after the infection
however this neutralizing
antibody response seems to can be last
quite long
and still 150 days are still above the
positive line
and then the fourth group which is also
a major group called the persistent
group
they are from beginning till the end
obtained a very high amount of
neutralizing antibody response
and then the last group which is quite a
special and quite individual
is they have relatively medium level of
response in the beginning and
somehow have a higher response later
it could due to other second infection
or
other diseases which they need to find
out later
so this study already gave us the first
hint that
you know even though everyone can be
infected with the virus but that doesn't
mean that you are immune to post
infection because it could be belongs to
any of these five groups that you don't
know
and some people could have a longer term
of protection and some have a
very short term and so with this study
the research group also proposed a way
to identify the
neutralizing antibody levels so
they draw these three lines under the
30 percentage of inhibition they call it
negative or
also suggested by our kid
and then they have under 50 of
inhibition they call it a low
immune response uh between 50
and 80 percent of inhibition they
suggest it is a medium level of
neutralizing antibody response and above
80 percent
they say it is a high immune response
and most likely they are protected
for your information the c-pass kit is
also have an
official application already it is
acknowledged
by the fda that c-pass can be used for
qualifying
the uh covalescent plasma quality
as well as the kit can detect the
examples have above 68
inhibition and this convolution plasma
can be used for
treatment so
in the very end i would like to give you
a
unpublished very prim preliminary data
from our collaborations
that they have performed
post-vaccination evaluation
and monitoring those patients after the
vaccination
and how their respond to the vaccine
so as you can see this group of study
those patients
have been vaccinated with either moderna
or physio vaccine and they have
quite different response especially
after those one
as you see from the left figure so after
those one some people may think oh i
am i'm already vaccinated i'm safe and
you see
this is not the case some people already
have high inhibition
after the vaccination but many people
are
various post the first vaccination
and after the second dose of vaccination
even there are still quite a few
individuals have medium level of
response
either pfizer or medona
vaccine and importantly
this study also gave us a blimp of how
different ages respond to the
vaccination
as you can see from the right hand side
figure after the first dose
the younger group seems to have a much
better response to the vaccine where the
older elderly group
have much slower response and they post
the first vaccine
many of them doesn't show any positive
threat
across the positive threshold and even
after the
those two and some old people have less
response and however you can also see
young patients could also have low
response
post to the second vaccine
so here's comes my summary of today's
talk
as you already see the presence of
binding antibody may not guarantee the
presence of neutralizing antibody
and the neutralizing antibodies are
important biomarker for possible
immunity and c-pass also our serology
our tests are the best choice for
determining
the new neutralizing antibodies in the
patient samples
however with the c-pass kit there are
still quite
open questions waiting for us to answer
is everybody vaccine means everyone has
immunity is there a cure from south
korea too means that you are safe
this is a long way to go for the science
globally to answer those questions
well c-pass can be the tool for you
to help you to answer the questions with
c-pass you can use it for validating
your vaccine
and drug development and you see that
the c-pass is designed for plasma
and serum samples detection for
neutralizing antibodies
but from the mechanism you can
understand this
can be also a perfect tool to validating
the antibody drugs that blocking the
viral entry
it can be also a perfect tool for that
for instance
secondly how we define the herd immunity
this is still a debate in many many
countries nowadays
i think it's still a global problem
because
we could not just understand yet that
what is the threshold for reach
the herd immunity well c-pass is a tool
to help you to define this
threshold line and we hope soon with the
global effect
we can understand this threshold better
and we can draw the line
much faster and allow the global
traveling
back again and the third of course the
bus
can help you and help your country to
monitoring the vaccine efficiency
and i already showed you in our last
unpublished data
that um even though everyone can be
vaccine but doesn't mean everyone
is protected very well with a different
level of immune response so with the
c-pass tour
that you can better monitoring past
vaccination how the whole population is
respond
to the vaccine
so if you have more questions you can
come to us to understand it better
so in the end i want to thank you for
your attention and
i mentioned before if you have more
questions and want to understand our kid
better
you can come to us for more information
and thank you